[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a brazilian dystopian
thriller series called three percent
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set far in
the future when the world has been
divided into two halves the first half
is called the offshore where people live
in luxury they have everything they want
in life money happiness entertainment
and so on while the second one is a slum
with no hospitals schools medicines
vaccines or employment every person from
the slums is given a single chance in
their lives to upgrade to offshore when
they turn 20 they have to go through a
selection procedure mainly referred to
as the process only three percent of the
people are selected in the said
procedure the selected ones get to live
their life free of all problems while
the others are sent back to the slums to
continue their miserable way of living
one morning it is announced that the
104th process is about to start everyone
who has registered for the process is
requested to come to the headquarters
one of the participants this year
includes a girl named michelle a ring
behind her ears tells her that she will
reach the headquarters in 40 minutes the
device was inserted when she registered
for the process everyone who has
participated has a device embedded in
them that acts as their official
identity michelle and her friend from
the block named bruna nervously make
their way to the headquarters alongside
several other 20 year olds they are made
to change into the uniform before
entering following that the chief
overseer of the process named ezekiel
gives them a speech about the importance
of the program it turns out that the
program was invented by someone called
the founding couple he doesn't go in
depth about the founders but mentions
the rebellious group who opposed the
idea after the speech ezekiel meets a
new employee named aline she reveals
that she has come from offshore to
evaluate his performance ezekiel is not
happy about the intrusion but cannot go
against the orders from the higher
officials meanwhile the participants are
sent to the interview rooms to be
evaluated by the officers from offshore
this is their first task and the ones
who are deemed unfit will have to return
home before the competition even starts
michelle's interviewer asks her several
personal questions about her life she
reveals that her boyfriend came as a
participant last year and hasn't
returned home she assumes he succeeded
but the interviewer suggests it can be
otherwise he might have died in an
unfortunate event which is not uncommon
for the participants to test her
emotional dependency on her boyfriend
she is asked to remove a locket that is
very significant to her when she does it
without hesitation the interviewer
selects her at the same time a guy named
marco confidently answers all the
questions everyone in his family has
always passed this election so he is
confident that he can make it to the end
his lack of fear gets him through the
first round the same cannot be said for
a guy named alex he confidently talks
about himself for 20 minutes but is
rejected because his words didn't sound
authentic he makes a fuss about the
competition being unfair before being
taken away then we are introduced to
joanna a girl who doesn't like to talk a
lot she is the smartest out of the lot
that doesn't go unnoticed by the
interviewer hence she is selected as
well lastly there is fernando a
handicapped man whose chances of
survival are less because of his
disability still his determination gets
him through the interview the group
ignores each other for the time being
unaware that their fates are about to
intertwine somewhere else in the
facility an employee named agata has
found a mole in their program it turns
out that a man has been sent by the
rebellious group called the cause to get
information from the inside he is
currently being tortured to reveal who
else is in on the plan after being
severely beaten he reveals that the new
batch of participants also has a mall
ezekiel and agata have to remove the
person as soon as possible to maintain
peace throughout the rest of the program
but they have to find out who the person
is first in the slums a meeting takes
place between the members of the rebel
organization the cause they believe
everyone deserves a quality life and the
process is just propaganda to create
higher and lower classes in society the
leader of the group is confident that
the person he sent in the program won't
be caught back in the headquarters alex
commits the unthinkable because he
wasn't selected the others are shocked
by the incident and have to be taken to
the other room by the officials after
that their ear devices are scanned to
make sure they are registered
participants joanna notices that the guy
in front of her named raphael has three
stitches behind his ears which is
different from the usual two-stitch
implant she calls him out for being a
fraud but he insists he was legitimately
registered when scanned the monitor
verifies him joanna is sure that he has
passed the test using a trick but she
doesn't notify the officials planning to
use the information to her advantage
then the time they have been waiting for
finally arrives and they are taken to a
room for their first task a set of
building blocks have been placed in the
middle of the table the participants
have to use them to build nine cubes in
10 minutes the task starts but fernando
struggles to reach the blocks michelle
helps him out of instinct before taking
the blocks for herself they immediately
get to work and continue as the timer
ticks in the last few seconds michelle
struggles to create the last cube seeing
her struggle fernando helps her and
creates a bigger cube out of the eight
cubes she had already created when the
timer stops raphael is still one cube
behind so he steals from a guy beside
him the management lets him get away
with it and he passes the round
similarly joanna has created 11 cubes
which makes her pass as well michelle
also has nine cubes although one of them
is bigger which makes her pass after the
game everyone starts looking at raphael
differently they call him a cheater and
talk behind his back he deliberately
causes a fight and gets beaten up by a
group of people when they eventually
stop the participants who were insulting
him earlier now sympathize with him his
plan works but it doesn't go unnoticed
by a smart joanna she asks him to be on
her side because if he betrays her she
will tell the official about his false
registration in ezekiel's office aline
is interviewing him on his way of
handling the process she is eager to
find a flaw in his work so she can take
over his position for this purpose she
also brings up his wife's name but
before we get to know more about her
they are interrupted meanwhile agata
finds out that either michelle or bruna
is the mole from the rebel group they
are brought aside and asked to reveal
which one of them is with the group the
two have been neighbors all their lives
and have always been close to each other
if they do not tell the truth agata will
have no way but to kill both of them
when she is not looking michelle
suggests they attack her since it's the
only way to survive bruna agrees to the
plan in the heat of the moment agata
returns but michelle betrays bruna at
the last second making her the only one
who attacks agata in the following
commotion she is shot dead and michelle
is let free it is then revealed that
michelle is actually the mole and is
working for the rebel group although she
and bruna had been friends since
childhood she sacrificed her for a
bigger purpose the story about her
boyfriend was also made up to be
selected in reality she is going
offshore to look for her brother who
went through the process and never
returned in the following scene we are
introduced to fernando's background he
was raised by his father who fostered in
him the singular purpose of passing the
process all his life all fernando has
known is to not let his disability be a
drawback between him and offshore during
a physical check he is taken to a doctor
who injects him with a medicine to his
surprise the medicine induces pain in
his legs for the first time in his life
the doctor affirms that if he passes the
process he will be able to get proper
treatment and can walk someday fernando
doesn't know how to feel about the news
because he had already accepted that he
will never walk for the next task the
participants are put into a group and
taken to a room it consists of four
mannequins at the dinner table with
different expressions on their faces the
group has to figure out what happened to
the woman in navy blue clothing they
quickly begin to analyze the situation
suggesting their own ideas after a lot
of contemplating fernando comes to the
conclusion that the lady was poisoned
her husband is the man sitting by her
because both of them have dirt on their
shoes so they must be the guests at the
other couple's house however in the time
of emergency she is turning toward the
other man this could mean that she was
having an affair with him and hence was
poisoned by his wife who cooked the meal
this also explains the expressionless
face of the wife fernando is goddamn
sherlock holmes the group agrees with
the suggestions but raphael objects no
one cares because raphael is an idiot he
proposes the theory that the woman is
having an allergic reaction to the
silver cutleries since everyone is
wearing at least one silver jewelry and
the woman is wearing a glass ring and a
wooden necklace he assumes she is
allergic to silver she is turning toward
the man other than her husband because
he is a doctor on looking through the
drawers they find diagrams of the human
body which hints towards the same but
this still doesn't explain why the host
female has an expressionless face joanna
who had been quiet the entire time
reveals that the woman is blind because
she has no lamp on her side of the study
table they check the other drawer and
find a book written in braille in the
end raphael's assumption is proven to be
true still one of their teammates is
eliminated for doing nothing to help the
group for the third round ezekiel asks
aline for help to monitor the game since
he is short-staffed she accepts the
offer but is a bit suspicious of ezekiel
hence when the competition starts she
goes looking for him and finds him
exiting the headquarters he wears a
beaten up robe and goes into the slums
disguised as a beggar at the same time
the remaining groups are taken to a room
each for this round they are given six
coins for seven people in the room the
group will have to collectively decide
who to eliminate in 15 minutes at last
the ones who walk out with a coin will
pass raphael takes a coin in his hand
claiming it as his own he is determined
to win the round one way or the other
but when marco forcefully asks him to
return the coin he has to oblige after
contemplating the group settles on
voting initially everyone votes for
rafael because of his obvious unlikable
personality but then michelle votes for
joanna joanna looks at rafael asking him
to take a stand for her afraid that she
will reveal his secret he does as told
and casts his vote for fernando since he
has the least chance of winning anyway
raphael wants to throw him under the
boss however fernando argues that the
doctor told him he can get proper
treatment offshore this means she
believed his disability is not a
drawback at last the group settles to
draw names and let fate decide who wins
outside aline is monitoring ezekiel's
every move he goes deep into the
underdeveloped city in disguise but
doesn't seem to stop anywhere suddenly
he notices the camera glowing green and
realizes someone is watching him he runs
away and drops a bunch of fruit on his
way because his face is not clear in the
videos aline has to think of another way
to expose his truth in the meantime the
group resorts to drawing out a ribbon
and eliminating whoever gets the
shortest piece at last joanna gets it
and is eliminated as the winners walk
outside the last guy realizes he has no
coin it turns out that joanna had stolen
it while the others argued so even
though she lost she tricked the last guy
into being eliminated if you can't beat
him make sure they lose too she smugly
joins the rest of the group in the last
scene ready to do anything to win
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching